[Music]
food as a language
food allowed me to become an artist
what i want to do is to invite you to
really understand and appreciate
vegetable on the deeper level
[Music]
i don't like the convention of things
but i do things because i want change to
happen
[Music]
i'm going to show you how to make
vegetarian recipes at home
to impress your family and friends
i guess ready
whether you meet either a vegetarian
this class is for you i'm going to show
you how to peel asparagus all the
asparagus here at the tip so you don't
crush the tip
i would say you undress the asparagus
so good
wow
[Music]
all right so we are grilling the melon
oh yeah it's okay if you get messy your
hand's gonna smell like garlic so just
put a little bit of lemon on my hand
this is not about perfection just wash
it like this it's about deliciousness my
restaurant actually cran means workshop
in english
oh yes this is good a place where you
bring your creativity beautiful
[Music]
if you want to become a cook
you have to understand where things come
from get to know your farmers
cook local
when you have the best ingredient voila
la tomat tujarda then you can do the
best cooking
doesn't matter your experiences in the
kitchen i'm inviting you to think
differently about food
dominican is a
master class
[Music]
foreign
[Music]